tell me a little bit about Sony and
Marvel coming together to do this and
why you guys were able to bridge that I
know you guys have known each other for
a long time
I think that we've been friends for a
long time we've been fellows spider-man
lovers for a long time and Kevin came to
me with a really fabulous idea and ideas
are everything
bringing spider-man into the universe
where he belongs as all the fans know
interacting with other characters for
the very first time and it was it seemed
like the right time to do it hey
everybody is Charlie everyone is
freaking out because news just broke
that Marvel lost the spider-man
character back to Sony it's really
complicated goes all the way to the top
between Kevin Feige and Marvel and Tom
Rothman at Sony we're doing the Avengers
endgame and spider-man far from home
blu-ray giveaways all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
your best spider-man 3 theory on the
video now that Marvel just apparently
lost spider-man
everybody's theories are gonna have to
change in a big way what happened was
news just broke that Marvel will not be
producing spider-man films anymore
meaning that's the sharing arrangement
going up in flames Kevin Feige
supposedly isn't going to be involved in
the making of spider-man 3 this is such
a big deal that even Ryan Reynolds is
chiming in people asking we're never
gonna get to see spider-man and Deadpool
in a movie together and he says you can
see it in my heart so that lets you know
the severity of the situation but right
now there are two more spider-man films
planned with Tom Holland in the director
John Watts so instead of doing a trilogy
they are planning on doing four films
with Tom Hollands spider-man character
beyond that who knows but one of those
sequels is definitely going to be the
venom crossover that they were talking
about during spider-man far from home
press junkets Kevin Feige said yes Sony
is definitely planning on crossing over
her Tom Hollands spider-man with venom
at some point come on man please
[Music]
the reason why the deal fell through
sounds more complicated than it is
but I'm just reading from the article
that broke the news here Disney asked
that future spider-man films be 50/50
co-financing arrangement between the
studios meaning that Disney would reap
some of the box-office profits of future
spider-man films what had happened in
the past is is that part of the terms of
the sharing arrangement were that Sony
would take a hundred percent of the
box-office take Marvel would make all of
its money on the spider-man toys comic
books and other merchandise
spider-man far from home just made over
a billion dollars at the box office
Marvel and Disney don't see a dime from
any of that it all goes to Sony
apparently when Disney presented the
terms of this new arrangement 50/50
sharing the profits Sony turned them
down flat and that's Tom Rothman not Amy
Pascal Amy Pascal used to be the
president of Sony but after the big Sony
hack she got pushed out and just became
a producer managing the spider-man films
interestingly enough she is actually
team Kevin Feige she was all about
bringing spider-man into the MCU so for
all the hates she gets online she was
actually a big part of bringing
spider-man to Marvel I thought oh my god
this would be fantastic this is the only
way to do it because the truth is is
that when you know we worked with Kevin
on the first couple of movies because he
worked with avi any worked at Marvel at
that time it's worked at all time and in
later years when he was really busy
becoming himself he would you know read
scripts and help but he he I wanted him
to really help you know and I wanted I
wanted his real brain on this because
there is nobody better at it
the real villain of this story is Tom
Rothman at Sony so a lot of people now
are worried please don't let a via rod
anywhere near these spider-man sequels
maybe you're a fan of his maybe not but
he's the one that's managing their venom
franchise technically Amy Pascal is only
involved with the core spider-man films
then you have all the venom verse stuff
that's going on that's all a V Arad
apparently Sony came back and countered
with an idea that they would give them a
little bit
of the box-office gross Disney said that
wasn't enough and then both parties went
their separate ways that's not the end
of it though that's not the end of the
story even though a lot of people are
reporting that Marvel completely lost
spider-man there are things that could
change down the line to allow spider-man
to continue to be in Marvel films but it
would require a really big late save in
the game for right now it really does
look like spider-man is out of the MCU
so it does make a little more sense why
Kevin Feige wasn't talking about
spider-man 3 during their big Marvel
phase 4 panel Sony wants to produce
these movies on a regular schedule of
venom movie every two years a spider-man
film with Tom Holland every two years so
spider-man 3 will probably still drop
summer 2021 then two years after that in
2023 their big spider-man for venom
crossover or sinister 16 movie or
live-action spider-verse movie Amy
Pascal did reveal that they had plans
for live-action spider-verse at some
point they didn't say anything about
Miles Morales they just said a
live-action spider-verse any chance
there's a multiverse in which Andrew
Garfield spider-man until you acquire
spider-man and spider-man all meet
together but would you want that would
you we want that it would be really
really cool the fans really want so
whether Marvel and Sony decide to do
that it's not up to me I thought walking
like Kevin this is what we're doing on
the next one yeah but it would be what's
gonna happen with Peter Parker in the
MCU now though he just disappears from
future Avengers vents nobody gives him a
call nobody talks about him per the
terms of this sharing arrangement they
wouldn't even be able to mention
spider-man in future Avengers movies so
imagine a scenario in Avengers 5 where
they're all talking about the snap and
the things that have come before were
putting a new team together and they
can't talk about what spider-man did
during Avengers infinity war in Avengers
endgame he wasn't there a kid named
Peter Parker wasn't there a kid a couple
years ago that Iron Man died and gave
this billion-dollar orbital weapons
platform to what are we gonna do about
that should someone go grab those
glasses from him so our reaction
obviously I'm really pissed off that
things didn't work out between Disney
and Sony of course it's going to be a
bunch of business
people to mess the deal up well that's
fantastic a really smart decision young
man's dad it's God poof
don't blame Kevin Feige for this he just
delivered two of the highest-earning
spider-man films of all times
spider-man far from home is getting
ready to be the biggest box-office
earner that Sony has ever had of any
kind of movie not just spider-man films
but it's getting ready to beat sky falls
record as big as Sony movie of all time
so Kevin Feige delivered as promised
give us a billion dollars and we'll come
back to the table so biggest predictions
about what's gonna happen next is
spider-man 3 will be closer to a
sinister six movie than you would have
expected before because Kevin Feige
isn't involved with a story Sony clearly
wants to leverage its biggest characters
and that is the sinister six characters
people like Norman Osborn and then their
venom franchise because venom earned so
much money for them it was such a big
surprise of course they're gonna want to
combine those franchises to try and get
the synergy of even more box-office
profits and while I am pissed about them
losing spider-man at least temporarily I
am still kind of excited about the idea
of spider-man vs. venom in spider-man
getting the symbiote eventually the
director of the movie already said that
Kraven the hunter was his lead pick for
spider-man 3 obviously it's gonna be
more of a John wick 3 movie with
everybody coming for spider-man Jay
jonah jameson will be back it feels like
it's a little too soon to do every
sinister 6 character but if they spend
enough money to get some of those actors
back they would probably show up in a
post-credits scene and you would see
them all for real in spider-man 4 in
some version of a venom crossover either
using the multiverse but I guess now
that Sony technically has the character
back they can just say that venom has
been in San Francisco this whole time
and he just shows up in New York City
nearby where Peter Parker is and then
they go at it you don't have to use the
multiverse at all because that was still
when the MCU was technically a separate
entity from the venom franchise in the
venom verse that Sony had Tom Hollands
contract I believe is up after
spider-man 3 so he'll have to Reese on a
new contract after that and if he
continues to be spider-man they're not
gonna stop making spider-man films after
that spider-man venom crossover but they
will have to figure out who's gonna be
the new director who's gonna be writing
and if they want to recast spider-man
but I would think that they would stay
with Tom Holland as
long as they give him enough money to
stick around our she would play
spider-man until like I can't walk
anymore
I loved his character so much and it was
like my childhood dream to play this
character you know I'm loving it I'm
really enjoying it I'm really loving
what we can do with this movie and the
people that we can kind of touch and the
amazing things we were able to do with
the platform that this movie gives us
that doesn't cancel any of the plans for
Marvel's Secret Wars they can still do
that movie they can still do
spider-man's symbiote in that way way
down the road six seven years because
that movie is so far off that there's
plenty of time for them to come back to
the table and work out a new sharing
arrangement for the spider-man character
so don't go throwing yourself out of
window because this seems like the end
of the world they could still save the
day in the last minute but don't be
surprised if spider-man 3 does wind up
happening without marvel if they're able
to come back to the table it might not
be till a little bit later than that
because of this news everyone post your
new spider-man 3 in spider-man 4 venom
crossover theories in the comments below
the funny thing about this is that I had
recorded an entire Eternals video
literally just stopped the minute that
this news broke so I'll finish that
video and post it tomorrow the next day
the big Marvel d23 phase 4 panel is this
weekend they'll be dropping footage for
the phase 4 movies I'll do videos for
everything but leave your requests in
the comments below and if you have big
questions about the future of spider-man
I'm sure it'll take a couple spider-man
videos this week to work through what's
going to happen with the future of that
franchise in that character in the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
while you wait for that everybody click
here to learn about why the Russo's are
talking about Nova in Avengers endgame
and click here for my spider-man far
from home post credits scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]